-Now, Scarlett, you played
Black Widow for years,
so we thought we'd put your
Marvel knowledge to the test.
It is time for the
"One-Second Marvel Quiz."
Here we go.
-♪ One, One-Second Marvel Quiz ♪
-Oh...no.
-Now, here's --
here's how it works.
We're going to play
a Marvel clip,
but it's going to be
just one second long.
And we're gonna take turns --
-What?!
-We're gonna take turns
guessing what the clip is from.
If we're wrong, the other person
gets a chance to steal.
Scarlett, you're our guest,
so you'll go first.
Let's see the first clip.
-Uh-oh.
-There you go.
-What? That was it?!
-Classic. Classic!
-What --
I don't even know what I saw.
-Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Watch.
Watch again. Here we go.
Can we play it one more time?
-I can't --
I -- Huh?!
-I think I know what this is.
-That was so fast!
-I think this is --
'Cause everyone's
wearing their masks --
-Is it "Guardians"?
-This is from "Spider-Man."
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Has Tom Holland played this?
Did he play that --
play this game?
-I'm just auditioning
'cause you never know when
they're gonna need another --
they're gonna need
another Spider-Man.
I got the wrist thing going.
All right.
It is my turn.
Let's see the next Marvel clip.
-I got him!
-What?!
-No.
-You're supposed to know that?
-This is actually hard.
What is "I got him"? I don't --
That could be "Swingers."
I don't --
Maybe it's not even Marvel.
Let me see it again. It's
Favreau. I know it's Favreau.
So it's "Iron Man."
-I got him!
-I'm gonna say "Iron Man."
-[ Buzzer ]
-All right. There you go.
You -- You get to steal it.
-I think it's from "Iron Man 2."
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you kidding me?!
Are you joking, judges?!
Oh. "Iron Man 2"?
Stop it!
Oh, my gosh. All right.
-I -- I had
the unfair advantage.
I was in that film.
-Of course you were.
You said, "You certainly did,"
after he said, "I got him!"
-I responded to that line, yes,
the famous "I got him."
-Let's throw up the next clip.
This is your guess on this one.
-Excelsior.
-Oh, that's from
"Avengers 2: Age of Ultron."
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
-Whoa. Gosh. You are good.
All right.
-I was also in that,
so, again, unfair advantage.
-Yeah, oh, yeah.
Still, that was Stan Lee.
I'm trying to remember --
This is tough for me.
All right. I'm up.
Let's see the clip.
This is for me.
-I'm a trickster.
-That's Matt Damon doing Loki.
It's in "Thor: Ragnarok."
[ Bell dings ]
It's him playing -- Yeah.
It was very good.
I love -- That was very funny.
I knew that one.
All right. Here we go.
It's your turn.
Let's run the next Marvel clip.
♪♪
-Wait. What is the --
-Wait, wait.
Does that say Blockbuster Video?
-Yeah.
-That's "Captain Marvel," right?
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's good.
That is good. I was not --
I was going to say "Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure."
I had no idea.
-Can we just see,
what's the score here?
I have 3, and you have 2.
Oh, you're right behind me.
-Oh, yeah. Oh, I can come back.
Oh, no problem. I got this one.
Let's show my next clip.
-Okay.
-And I'll just guess it
right now. Here we go.
-Gross.
-I got this.
It's "Howard the Duck."
-Does this make it easier?
-That is "Howard the Duck"
because Howard the Duck
is a Marvel character.
I know that. It was -- I think
it was a George Lucas movie
at one point, "Howard the Duck."
It did not work,
but it is in the Marvel thing,
and so they threw it
in the end of --
either "Guardians
of the Galaxy" 1 or 2.
[ Bell dings ]
-One?
-There you go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just take it.
Just take it and walk away
from the vehicle.
They said yes.
-It felt --
It felt to me like you may
have said two movies there.
-It's all right.
It doesn't matter what I said.
The judges gave a ding,
and once they give the ding,
you're allowed to sing.
You know what I'm saying?
That's the -- Now, here we go.
This is the final round.
Okay? And this one
is worth 1,000 points.
Whichever one of us shouts out
the correct answer first wins.
-Wha--
-Ready?
Let's play the clip. Go.
-Mother...
-Uh, uh, "Avengers" something.
-Oh, oh! Wait, wait!
"Infinity War"!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How do you know that?
"Infinity..."
Scarlett Johansson.
I was gonna say "Endgame."
You did it!
Sorry to put you on the spot.
Her new movie, "Black Widow,"
is coming to theaters July 9th.
That's what I'm talking about.